guerre en ukraine qui se répercute sur
de nombreuses économies l'économie
espagnole on voyait tout à l'heure avec
badri 17 inflation record depuis des
années 9 8% répercussions également sur
les projets de conquête spatiale entre
la russie l'europe les états unis alors
que moscou ramène aujourd'hui sur terre
deux cosmonautes russes et un astronaute
américain il occupait ces dernières
semaines jss la station spatiale
internationale en juin est censé
atterrir au kazakhstan dont l'après midi
on en parle avec notre invité du jour
tout de suite cet olivier tanguy
olivier tanguy bonjour vous êtes
médiateur scientifique rédacteur en chef
de l'actualité spatiale cité de l'espace
de toulouse spécialiste donc de
l'astronautique
notamment un mot peut-être de ce retour
sur terre annoncée on a beaucoup parlé
dès le début de la guerre de cette
cohabitation qui avait lieu malgré tout
à des milliers de kilomètres au dessus
de nos têtes on aura peut-être
l'occasion de poser la question à ces
assauts de savoir comment ça s'est passé
entre eux
en théorie ça se passe bien parce que
d'abord il faut savoir qui est un code
de conduite à bord de la station
spatiale internationale c'est là que les
astronautes dans le lit ss n'ont pas le
droit de faire des déclarations qui
pourraient être vu comme une critique
des pays partenaires il ya quand même
des rumeurs qui disaient que les deux
cosmonautes russes lun lun avait plutôt
un soutien pro ukrainien et l'autre un
soutien pro pro poutine ce qui laissait
entendre qu'il y aurait peut-être eu des
discussions un peu animé au dessus de au
dessus de nos têtes quoi qu'il en soit
ils reviennent sur terre donc
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment l'occasion
pour nous nous nous pencher sur
ces projets qui certains ont dit serait
remise en cause dans un futur très
proche
certains projets ont été déjà
concrètement remis en cause il faut
savoir par exemple les équipes russes
qui opère le lanceur russe soyouz depuis
le centre spatial guyanais c'est-à-dire
à kourou en gros pour simplifier ses
équipes ont été rappelés donc bien là
s'est terminé plus de vols soyouz depuis
la guyane et le rover martien un exo
mars rover européens mais qui atterrit
sur un module russe et qui part avec un
lanceur russe tout cela se devait
décoller en septembre bien pour
l'instant cette coopération est mise à
l'arrêt on avait entendu début mars
aussi les russes plaisanté sur le retour
du cosmonaute américain laissant
entendre qu'il pouvait rester dans
l'es16 c'est aussi la menace qui a été
proférée de faire tomber 10 et 16 sur
sur nos têtes ça vous vous l'avez pris
au sérieux alors pas vraiment parce que
ça c'était plus de la communication il
faut savoir que ça a été relayée
notamment par dimitri rogozine qui est
le patron de l'agencé roskosmos c'était
de la posture la coopération a continué
la preuve aujourd'hui vous avez un
américain qui revient dans un vaisseau
russe avec des équipes américaine au
kazakhstan qui vont prendre en charge
monsieur marc vendée et puis les deux
cosmonautes russes vont partir en
banlieue de moscou à la cité des étoiles
donc pour l'instant ça se déroule il
faut savoir que le commandant de liesse
s anton chkaplerov a donné la clé avant
de partir la clé 10 et 16 c'est un
symbole bien sûr un américain thomas
marshburn et il a dit les ss est un
symbole d'amitié de coopération je crois
que le message de continuité en tout cas
pour la station spatiale internationale
est assez fort si je vous écoute bien
aujourd'hui vous ne redoutez pas
d'impact de cette guerre ans en ukraine
sur les projets de conquête
spatiale on évoquait ces résolutions qui
ont déjà été prises à très court terme
et dans un plus long terme vous êtes
plutôt optimiste alors non il ya des
impacts c'est très clairement il ya des
impacts qui ont déjà eu lieu on sait par
exemple qu'un lanceur américain le
lanceur antarès ne va plus avoir de
moteurs russes dans les mois qui
viennent donc ça va poser un problème
il sert à l'envoi de cargos vers l' iss
faudra trouver un autre plan on sait
qu'il ya plus de vols soyouz depuis la
guyane il ya plus le rover exomars et
d'autres choses qui vont il ya des
coopérations qui vont s'arrêter comme ça
est ce que pourront reprendre après
c'est là qu'est la véritable question et
ça c'est la géopolitique qui donnera la
réponse s'est pas véritablement le
spatial celle vous inquiète vous ces
représailles russe dans ce domaine
spatiale la russie et les etats unis ont
toujours été finalement en concurrence
un remontant rien qu'il ya 50 ans la
course pour les premiers pas de l'homme
sur la lune ce n'est pas nouveau mais
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être de nature à
inquiéter davantage
ça peut inquiéter davantage en ce sens
que de toute façon même quand il ya
coopération vous avez toujours un
partenaire qui veut être un petit peu en
avant la coopération elle s'entend bien
si on est à peu près sur un pied
d'égalité technique ce qui est un peu le
cas dans les ss à la station spatiale
internationale après ce qui va être
difficile c'est notamment pour le
commercial peut-être que l'agent spécial
russe va avoir un déficit de confiance
parce que il faut savoir qu'il ya eu des
satellites britannique et indiens des
satie de connectivité web wan web qui
n'ont pas été lancés c'est à dire le
patron de l'agencé spatiale a dit je ne
les lance pas par réplique aux sanctions
donc basse cet opérateur britannique aux
indiens s'est tourné vers la mairie 15 p
6 est ce qu'après la conscience la
confiance pourra revenir ça c'est
surtout ça et je vous dis ça ça dépend
plus de la géopolitique de ce qui va se
passer dans le conflit ukrainien qu'une
réelle volonté des partenaires sociaux
une dernière question assez rapidement
s'il vous plaît cette cette guerre ne
renforce t elle pas finalement
n'accélère t'elle pas là la quête
d'autonomie spatiale
alors sa malle accéléré mais il faut
savoir que cette quête d'autonomie
spatiale a toujours été là elle a
toujours existé et est même montée en
puissance ces dernières années si par
exemple en europe on à ariane 5 es bega
et bientôt à rien 6 c'est parce qu'on a
toujours eu la volonté d'avoir une
souveraineté spatiale d'être indépendant
merci beaucoup d'avoir été à nos côtés
donc en cette journée ses répercussions
donc sur les projets spatiaux merci
beaucoup vous étiez donc notre invité du
jour